now food prices saw to a record rate in
December with some household skipping
meals to save money well let's bring in
our political correspondent Mario who's
at Sky News Center for us Murray good
morning to you so tell us about food
prices uh they're still going up
well unfortunately we've got quite a
stark level of figures coming out of the
British retail Consortium this morning
so not good news for Shoppers we've got
13 we've got a food inflation at 13.3
you can see there from the British
retail Consortium that's actually up 1.1
from uh last month that's also the
highest inflation rate in that category
on record so really really squeezing
household incomes then if we turn to
fresh food inflation that's even higher
that's gone up to 15 which is a 0.7
increase on last month again and again
that is a record-breaking inflation rate
for that food category as well now
potentially a silver lining is the shop
price inflation which is actually Fallen
slightly it's 4.1 down to 7.3 here so
that potentially is some level of Hope
but nonetheless inflation and food
inflation is still massively massively
High which is very very difficult for
households at the moment and especially
this is going to disproportionately
affect lower income households who are
obviously going to be spending more of
their daily salaries their monthly
salaries on Essentials like food and
energy now it's important to think okay
why is this happening well Energy prices
are high at the moment because of the
knock-on effect on the war in Ukraine
also the war in Ukraine is impacting the
price of animal feed and fertilizer as
well so it's all making it more
expensive to not just ship out the food
but actually produce it in the first
place but also at the moment inflation
is so so high even if perhaps it is
falling household incomes are not going
to see the benefit until it falls much
more drastically and that politically is
a bit of a bit of a difficult situation
for British soon that the government are
very much hoping and banking on
inflation falling as soon as possible so
that they can essentially try and get
back around the table with striking
workers and say here we are inflation's
coming down like we said it would it and
therefore now strikes are no longer
necessary and we can find a deal but
until that happens households all across
the country are really going to feel the
pinch they're going to find it very very
difficult and if we have any very very
cold snaps coming up in January and
February they're going to end up
spending more money again on energy
which is going to squeeze them even
further okay Mario for now thanks for
that